day two of the U.S president's official
visit provided the Diplomatic and
political centerpiece to this whole trip
Kennedy Reagan Clinton and now Biden
just four U.S presidents have addressed
The Joint houses of the Irish Parliament
and for Joe Biden this most Irish of
American leaders the occasion carried a
deep personal significance
people of Ireland it's so good to be
back in Ireland if you forgive the poor
attempted Irish
tamasha Walia I'm at home
one word
possibilities we believe anything is
possible we set our mind to it and we do
it together this is the United States
America and Ireland there's nothing
beyond our capacity if we do it together
and we've got to believe that we got to
know that because that's the history of
both our countries
Victoria state
Joe Biden has brought a heavyweight
Entourage to Ireland including his
secretary of state Anthony blinken and
agriculture secretary Tom vilsack
economic links the war in Ukraine and
ongoing difficulties with the peace
process in Northern Ireland all topics
of substantive discussion in the
president's bilateral with the Irish
leader Leo varadka we really do
appreciate your your leadership and your
personal leadership both in terms of
securing peace in Ireland but also in
trying to protect democracy and Liberty
here in Europe it's not just a
Sentimental visit there's a lot going on
behind the scenes we now have a very new
and complex geopolitical picture The
Fallout from the Ukraine war is changing
transatlantic relationships brexit is
changing transatlantic relationships
Ireland is stepping into a new position
for these reasons and that is something
that will be discussed between Ireland
the United States in this visit even if
we don't see it very publicly this is
[Music]
of course the symbolism is ever present
in sounding the peace spell with Irish
President Michael D Higgins Biden
literally giving his ringing endorsement
to the 1998 Good Friday agreement which
brought an end to the 30-year sectarian
conflict in Northern Ireland
the public and media reaction has been
overwhelmingly positive the only
hesitant reaction came from mishna
Michael Higgins enormous Bernie's
mountain dog which seemed unsure whether
approaching a U.S president might be a
breach of protocol
it is with some pride and no
exaggeration that the Irish government
describes relations between Dublin and
Washington as very very warm and a
relaxed looking Joe Biden clearly feels
he is among friends here but Thursday's
agenda also served to emphasize the
serious issues and ongoing challenges
that both countries share
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Dublin